hello everyone my name is Alex
kazachinski and this is my joint work
with Natalia hotel maiko and Vladimir
padolski title constant Dev sorting
Networks
so our context is the problem of sorting
in which we get an array of integers and
we want to Output these integers in the
non-decreasing order
and there is a classical class of
algorithms for this problem called
comparison-based algorithms
this algorithm is basically the only
thing you can do if your integers is
comparable so I would say it's better to
imagine that you have just n Stones of
different ways and your task is to all
the these Stones according to their
weights
uh but you can't just tell by looking at
them which one is heavy and which one is
lighter so we just have weights and you
can take any two stones and you can
compare them
and then what you are minimizing is the
number of comparisons you do now
searching networks again is a it's a
very restricted subclass of the class of
this comparison based algorithms in a
way sorting networks are non-adaptive
comparison based albums in which you
kind of don't see the results of
comparisons
well but then the question is
whether we can still do something in
this model if you don't see the results
of comparisons well well what's the
model uh now in the searching networks
you can imagine that you have n Stones
that lie that go in the row they align
the row and on some table let's say so
like it'll be here on the left uh we
have four stones and from bottom to the
top they go their weights are four one
three two and in the end we want them
and we want them uh to go in the
non-decreasing order with respect to
their store weights so it has to be one
two three four like on the right here
now what you can do you can just the
only thing you can do and one step is to
indicate a pair of positions and ask an
oracle to swap these two stones in these
positions if uh they go in the wrong
order
like I don't know like four and one here
on the left they go in the wrong order
and if you ask a an oracle to swap them
then in the result you will have one for
like in the next row
okay but the point is that Oracle
doesn't tell you whether he really
swapped these numbers or whether they
actually
were okay they were in a right order
and so what you can do is you just in
this model you can just indicate a
sequence of pairs of positions and just
Oracle performs with swaps if necessary
uh
and still in the end this sequence of
prayers of positions which is a sorting
Network
should always shoot
um correctly sort all possible inputs of
integers
and so here is an example
what we do in this exam so on the left
we have let's say some initial
uh array some initial row of stone some
initial array what we do is just we swap
we ask to swap
the first two arrays and then the second
uh the second two stones and then
uh uh the first two stones and then the
third and the fourth Stone okay
and and then what we do on the next
step
um
we kind of take
so we did two swaps so now we know that
and the second stone is the largest one
among the first and the second position
pizza and the fourth stone is the
largest one in the third in the fourth
position so now we take the second in
the fourth position so we kind of take
Stones two stones that were heavier in
their comparisons and then and we take
two large lighter stones and compare
them and after that
after so we already did four swaps uh
after that
um we just know that the fourth position
now contains like the heaviest of the
heaviest
and hence in the fourth position we have
the largest stone and the the first
position now has the lightest of the
lightests
and again this means that in the first
position we have
the right Stone the minimum weight
strong but again we don't really know
what happens on the second and the third
position and if we do just one more
Swope
so which
um
fixes the situation if it has to be
fixed
and so like so this is a searching
network with five swaps
but not just that it's also organized in
levels because
initially well I can do I can ask to
swap a pair of positions
but imagine uh but if they are like
disjoint like on the first
uh the first two swaps then I can
actually imagine that I do this always
at once
and this defines another very important
parameter of sorting networks called Dev
which is of course of interest if you
want to parallelize the execution of the
Sorting Network and the depth is just uh
at one imagine that at one step you can
do an arbitrary an arbitrary set of
swaps of disjoint swaps
and then the number of such steps where
in one step you can do it most n over
two swaps but they has to be disjoint is
the depth so here the depth is three we
do this algorithm in three steps but uh
we do five swaps
so sorting networks are studied since
1950s it's acquired an old topic and one
of the main interests
insulting networks is because they are
just made for Hardware this is a kind of
algorithms where you don't have any
conditional operators right so you don't
uh you have Justice
fixed uh sequence of commands and you
just do them regardless uh of what
happened previously and still there are
important problems in this area
and but first let's
um give just a slight overview what is
known about them well we'll be most
interested in the depth well because
let's say if you have deputies and we
know that we do it most D times n over
two swaps because at one step we can do
with most n over two just join swaps
and since sortic networks are still
comparison based algorithms uh there is
a standard information theoretical lower
bound which says that the number of
swaps has to be at least binary log of n
factorial which is one plus more of one
and binary log of n
and this automatically means that depth
should be at least logarithmic
in the number of integers you want to
sort and mostly specifically it has to
be more or less two binary at least two
binary log of n
well two plus smaller fan a small level
of one
now and on the other hand if we would
have a construction where the G is
logarithmic
in N we would automatically obtain this
would be a construction where the number
of small swaps is also asymptotically
optimal
now unfortunately the situation is kind
of like this
um there are many relatively simple
constructions where the depth is a log
squared then and so it gives the number
of swaps and log Square then which is
close to Optimal but not optimal
and there is only one construction where
depth is actually logarithmic simulated
and but there are
some
important drawbacks of these
constructions does the argument and the
constructions are very
complicated and it's
and it should be very hard to implement
this in Hardware
and the other problem is that the
constant before login is quite large
it's of order 1000 or something and in
order for this construction to
outperform you know all these standard
constructions where depth is log squared
then but the constant is some 2 or
something like that or even one and
n has to be really really huge
so the number problem here is to come up
with some is try to search a simple
construction or simple argument where
depth is still logarithmic and hopefully
the constant is not that large now in
terms of constant before log n so we
know that it isn't
there's some optimal constant we know as
I already said this is at least two but
there is there are some improvements of
this
um
foreign simple information theoretical
argument with the current best known is
3.27 login
and the upper bond which type of
similarity is far away from this 3.27
motivated by these questions we study
the following generalization of sortic
networks called case sorting Networks
so ordinary sorting networks are two
certain networks but in general in case
searching networks what you can do with
the unit cost you can indicate key
positions in the array and then you can
ask the Oracle to order
integers in these positions in the
non-decreasing order but without
touching any other positions of the
array
so in so instead and for inordinary
sorting networks we just do this but for
pairs of positions and now we can do
this for any K double organizations
now in this example this is more or less
actually the same example as we had
before but now we have eight inputs and
now K is four so the first step we
um
um in the first layer of our Network
we take the first four positions in the
second four positions and independently
we ask the Oracle to order them
now on the second layer what we do we
take the best Wells like the heaviest
two stones in the first two in the first
four and the heaviest two stones in the
second floor
and we ask to order them again and the
same so we take best of the best and
worst of the worst so after that we know
that the first and the second
and the first in the second array
position of the array you will have a
tool the most light stones
and in the seventh in the eighth
position you will have the headers and
the next to the heaviest Stone right
because these two were
winners of the winners and the first two
were Losers of the losers
and again once again we don't know what
happens in the middle for positions so
we do one more call to the Oracle which
sorts the middle four stalls
foreign
okay so what do we know about this model
let's start with something simple and
understand that the depth
now should be at least
a login based key why is that
well because if you consider just one
layer of your network
in one layer you just partition your
inputs into the positions in the array
into tuples of size K and you order your
array inside these doubles and then
every output
of one layer depends on the most K
positions in the previous
before the layer now if you have G
layers
uh every output of the network depends
on it most K to the D
uh initial positions in the array
now but obviously if the network Source
or inputs correctly then
um
every output should depend on all n
inputs so from that we did use that D
should be at least log n base K and
notice that in when K is 2
uh we actually had a very simple
argument showing something slightly
better we have two binary logs of N and
now having obtaining not one but two is
not that obvious and I will and we will
return to that
uh but um
and what we know
what else we know so now uh login base K
is a natural Benchmark for d and the
situation kind of repeats the situation
with k equals to
well there is but now there is only one
kind of simple construction where D is
quadratic in log n base K due to Parker
and Battery
and it was also noticed by
um
that um we can generalize the
sorting network of hty Commodities
meridi to the setting of key sorting
networks so again there is a simple uh
construction with quadratic which
quadratic and login base k and a
complicated and it has the same
drawbacks as in case it
k equals to construction with just login
basically depth
okay so now what we are actually doing
in this work a interested in the
following question let's say I'm fixed D
I say that D is some constant let's say
free or something
and then I studied the following
question I know that I can use only
three layers say of this uh k sorters
and then can how large K should be if I
want to sort n inputs so this is our
problem
and um the motivation that I'll explain
in a minute is that we can use
such constructions where D is constant
and hopefully K is not that large
iteratively by applying
uh it to its own
elements to get eventually a probably
good one a good
ordinary solving Network by recursion
okay let us discuss what we can achieve
by the question
assume that we have a construction of a
key sorting Network
for some constant Dev d
and K
which we will call the rity of the
network being significantly smaller than
the number of fields inputs
let's say that it's n to the alpha for
some Alpha smaller than one so let's
imagine that we have something like that
what we can do
well so it's a case starting Network so
it consists of D layers and each layer
[Music]
consists of several disjoint Kate apples
that are being sorted on this level
and instead
now we can apply this the same
Construction
to each of these K Tuple
and
it's because the task is the same we now
have to sort
K elements instead of n we know that we
can do this with rdk to the iPhone
right and in in N it becomes just n to
the alpha to the alpha so n to the alpha
Square
and Dev becomes G squared because we
have D layers and to simulate each layer
we need
game mole as n in total D Squared we can
repeat it once again
and then we will have def D cubed and
rtn to the alpha cubed and well any
number of times we can do that until
reality becomes 2 this happens for some
key number of this recursive iterations
and the depth of the resulting and this
will be just an ordinary resorting
network with k equals 2 and its depth
will be small D to the k
and then we can express capital D from
everything else by excluding T because
we know that it has to be such that n to
the alpha to the k equals two and doing
some calculation we obtained that
capital D the depth of the resulting
ordinary sorting network will be logged
n to some exponent and the exponent is
something like log of D base 1 over
Alpha
uh and it would be great if this
exponent let's say smaller than two at
least because as I as we've been
discussing there are Sim there are a lot
of constructions where the exponent is
two for the researching networks but
only one
uh where it's just logarithmic and very
complicated and it would be fine if it
would be nice if we would have some
simple construction and you know this
idea of just
um recursively applying the circuit to
itself is very simple it would be nice
if it would at least give us something
better than Square
hopefully it might
get
um something which is more or less close
to Optimal but who knows and to achieve
at least something better than the
square you can see that we have that
Alpha should be smaller than one divided
by square root of G
so finally our results so our problem
again is that we fix G and then we
consider all sorting networks uh
of Dev D with an inputs and then we are
interested in what is the minimal K such
that a k sorting network with such
parameters exists which if we fix D just
becomes a function of K and we
obtain a precise answer for all G up to
four
so let's see what we have so well first
we can for fun consider the case D
equals one and observe that obviously we
cannot do anything then just k equals n
because every output should depend on
every input
now it turns out that the same situation
is for D equals 2
this is even if you can
have two layers two steps of your
algorithms algorithm then you can not
sort all n inputs if you can attune cost
you can only sort smaller than a number
if it's in two steps so uh but uh for
already for D equals three the answer
becomes smaller than n and yet it is not
as impressive because it's again some
linear function and then
more precise more specifically it's the
minimum is exactly n over two rounded up
for every n
and finally for g equals fourth keep the
minimum K becomes sublinear more
specifically it becomes of order n to
the two-thirds
now uh
with regard to possible recursive
constructions this whole results are
negative
and let's see why because well at least
for D equals three we see that K is
linear in n and
um
in order to obtain something reasonable
from a recursive construction K had to
be something like n to the alpha or some
Alpha smaller than what and if you try
to do this with linear key defend over
two k uh you will get eventually we'll
get some sorting network of rt2 but its
depth will be even not super it will be
not poly logarithmic
well and now if you take D equals 4 and
start to do this you will get something
polygenic but it actually will be worse
than log Square then because to obtain
logs we're in as we saw on the previous
slide we have to have alpha 1 divided by
square root of G and if G is is four
it's one half and here the minimum
possible Alpha is two thirds so
unfortunately we don't get anything uh
interesting from it
and uh finally we also show General
lower Bound for arbitrary energy we show
that if we have a sorting network with a
case of the network
Dev G so we basically show that K is at
least n over 2 to the 1 divided by G or
two around the top
um
and also I have to note here that the
upper Bound for E equals 4 was actually
implicitly known so our contribution
here is uh
the lower bound the matching lower bound
and uh and final remarkable is that
um the lower Bound for arbitrary D is a
if you write it as a lower bound on uh D
you will obtain something
before I described you a simple argument
showing that g is at least log n
uh base K and here you can get two
before login so we will discuss it a bit
later
what's left open of course is whether
there exists some constant D at which
there exists the construction of a case
searching Network which after recursion
gives us something better than log
squared and at least
um so in other words uh we
we are asking whether there is
construction with some fixed D and K
which is n to the alpha for some Alpha
smaller than one over square root of d
uh and but
besides that it's also interesting to
figure out what is the minimum key for
RTD
and we don't know the exact answer
already for D equals five
so what we know is that from our
um General lower bound that Alpha is at
least
um one third
but uh what we also know is that Alf is
at most two-thirds but that's just an
upper Bound for D equals four which is
also obviously an upper Bound for g
equals five the more layers you have the
easiest for you
and let's say and also separate question
for some well uh let's say whether you
can achieve Alpha
at more say 0.44 why why this number
just because 1 divided by square root of
5 is something 0.44 and something else
if you have
0.44 then you will obtain something
better than log squared then after
recursion and just so and and not nobody
knows actually like it may happen at
some random depth uh let's say g equals
10 and just for for good for D equals 10
you need something better than
a 1 divided by square root of 10 and
that's
so for example Alpha
0.3 would would work and
in the rest of the video I would like to
present you our technique
um but let's start let us start the sub
notation so we represent sorting
networks as such diagrams where well
remember that sorting networks have
layers where on each layer we sort some
disjoint gate apples
of positions
and in our case k is 4 and these doubles
are given by colors so let's say on the
first layer the first Tuple
which is sorted is the first for
uh positions of the array
and this is given by the first uh for
blue circles
and likewise the second sorted Tuple is
the Tuple of the last four positions and
this is given by uh red circles
and uh we also have these Columns of
um
Square cells and this is just a
the content of our array at different
moments
so
um
let's say the leftmost column is the
content of our array the
at the very beginning and we assume that
the indices of the array
go from the bottom to the top
and the second column let's say is the
content of the array after the first
layer of the network so after we get the
sortings in with the gate up also in the
first layer and this Square cells we
will refer to them well their position
um
to specify their position there are two
ways so let's say consider the second
column
we will whenever convenient we will say
that these are cells after the first
layer and whenever possible these are
also sales before the second layer of
the
Network and for example output cells the
cells after the last layer in this case
this uh cells after the third layer
and what else I want to mention is that
uh in our lower bounds uh it is it will
be sufficient for us to only consider
arrays consisting of zeros and Watts and
I just would like to mention that
this is not strange because in fact
there exists a classical zero one
principle which says that as long as
your sorting Network
correctly assorts all arrays
consisting only of zeros and once it
correctly sorts all uh arrays of
arbitrary integer numbers now our main
technique is called access technique so
to Define it assume that we have a
sorting Network and we fix some
uh input array X which consists just of
zeros and ones and then we say that we
have access to some cell of the network
on input X if currently this cell
contains zero its value is zero but we
can change some of the input bits from 0
to 1 such that the value of this cell
becomes one
so in this example X is written in the
leftmost column it's zero one zero one
zero zero one zero
and for example I'm claiming that I have
access on this input to the following
orange cell and to see that
actually this access is established by
the following sequence of orange cells
first the first observation is that I
have access to all input cells in the
leftmost column that are equal to zero
because I can change them to one without
any restriction so in particular I have
an
an X I have access to the
orange cell on the bottom on the top of
the leftmost column
now uh in the first layer of my network
I have a red quadruple which sorts uh
the last four input
cells
and
um
currently in the last four input cells I
have just one
bit which is equal to one and if I
switch the last
the orange cell to one now in the
outputs of these red quadruples
quadruple I will have two ones and
because the outputs of the red quadruple
should be ordered it has to be this
orange
cell in the second column now what
happens in the second layer in
particular in the second layer I have
a red quadruple which takes
um
the seventh and the eighth cell and also
the third and the fourth cell
now currently
in the current picture that we see now
in this in the inputs of this red
quadruple we have three ones right and
one zero but if this orange cell uh
changes to one in the second column this
means that uh the number of ones in the
in this red quadruple in the second
layer now becomes four and hence it all
the outputs of the red quadruple in the
second layer should be also all ones and
hence in particular this Orange
um cell will become one
and in general so these are all uh cells
to which have access
on this input and it is important to
note that if we consider the last
column
and if our Network Source all input
correctly this means that we have access
to exactly one cell on each input namely
to the
topmost cell
with zero because
just because the
the last column
should be always sorted so it has to
have first some zeros and then some ones
they are
sure
we'll also need a element called access
stability so it assess the following we
have an access to some cell C some input
X
and then we switch some input and then
and then suppose that we switch some
input bit from zero to one well the
first possibility that c can become one
and then by definition we lose access to
it because we only have access to sales
with zeros
now in the statement of the limo is that
if C is still equal to zero then we
still have access to it uh
[Music]
and um this is just a monotonistic
argument so
um
if we know that before we made the
switch we had access to sheet through
some input bit
right and then we change some other
input bit because she didn't became Z
become zero and this means that we still
have access to C through the same input
bit as before
so after changing this the same input
beta say four to one C becomes one
because we also some other B became
equal to one and it can only have to
become one
as an illustration of our technique I'll
show you how to
uh establish our lower Bound for
arbitrary D which says that K should be
less than or two to the 1 divided by G
over to random app so basically it's a 2
over G
um and in Jones you you can rewrite this
lower bound and this will be now more or
less D it will state more or less that D
should be at least two times log n base
k
and uh recall that for k equals two uh
the same lower bound with coefficient 2
was a consequence of a simple
information theoretic argument and now
let's try it in that case and see
and we will see that actually now it
won't give us two here at least for
large scale so why is that so let's try
that so we can consider a more strong
stronger models and networks
and the model where you can just ask
[Music]
um
you can indicate any K Tuple
uh
uh of stones if we are in the framework
of stones and then the Oracle gives you
their order
uh so it's kind of a general comparison
based algorithm but but 4K larger than
tools so and obviously and um in the end
we want to know the ordering of all the
end stones but there are if uh n
factorial possible orderings
and each query basically has K factorial
different
results
and it shows that
um
the depth of the tree if you consider
like your algorithm in this model as a
tree
uh should have definitely login
factorial base K factorial which is
basically log n factorial divided by log
K factorial
and now if we represent it as a network
into each layer
uh we do at most n over K queries so we
obtained that as before we must have at
least log n factorial divided by log K
factorial and August divided by n over k
layers
but if n and K are sufficiently large
what happens so log n factorial is
basically and log n and log K factorial
is basically K log K so n and K cancel
out you obtain login divided by log K
and it's just login base K but without
any coefficient tool so for top 10 lower
boundary coefficient 2 in that case we
have to do something else and actually
access stability helps
so here is an argument with access
stability so we have to show this
inequality
and we assume for simplicities that g is
even
and we assume for contradiction that K
to the G over 2 is smaller than n over
2.
and then our network has G layers and
um let's consider the middle of our
Network that is a column of cells
um after the first day over two layers
and influently before the last year or
two layers and then let's put first
um
all zeros as inputs
and then
let's consider the column in the middle
and on the input of all zeros we have
some access to one of the cells
of this column because well if we just
fix any if we just flip any bit from
zero to one
then
one of the cells in in the in the column
in the middle also change it from zero
to one so let's fix this cell and let it
be a knowledge cell
so now what is drawn here
uh I observe that this orange cell
depends on at most n over 2 uh an effect
on less than n over two input cells
because there are D over two layers
between this orange node and input cells
and every cell depends on at most K
uh cells from the previous column
namely these are like these are cells
from the k tuples
from the corresponding K Tuple
and if we do go
backwards in for G over two layers then
instead of here we will have at most K
Over D over 2
cells
on which our orange cell may depend
and by our assumption this number is
smaller than n or two
now
um
what else we can not just that by the
same argument like uh
fewer than n over 2 output cells
may depend on the value of the orange
cell as well
meaning that
[Music]
um
for the rest of the output cells
their will you cannot change if we
change the value of the orange cell
so what we are starting to do so we
start
flipping input bits
from zero to one
one by one
um
but we do not touch these input cells on
which our orange cell may depend so
the only
a
flip the rest of the input cells and
there are more than n over two of them
and
um
so when we do this what happens in the
last column it should be
correctly ordered right so it just
happens that
um
[Music]
um
each time we take
you see uh
the top of zero and change it to one
now in this way we flip more than n over
two cells
and it means that at some moment
some cell
which is uh independent on the orange
some output cell which is independent of
the value of the orange cell
becomes one
but why
but this is actually a contradiction why
is this impossible so
so during the whole process first note
that the orange say the value of the
orange cell remains zero
because we do not change we only change
uh cells
that uh
do not uh which are not connected to
this orange cell
and then uh let's consider the moment
when we have this first red one
appearing outside the cells the set of
cells on which may depend on the orange
cell
but still at this very moment we have
access to the orange cell because it's
still zero we've had an access to it in
the beginning and then by access
stability we still have an access to it
this means that we can change this some
things that also these orange shells
changes to one but then still the same
red one should appear
because the output
column should be ordered
but the point is that uh since
um
this red one is out of the set
which may depend on this orange cell if
it cannot become it cannot flip from
zero to one if
uh deal if the the only thing which
changes in the middle column is the
orange
cell
so we obtain a contradiction
so this is it and
I have uh uh shown you
the details of the proof of our lower
Bound for arbitrary D and some
additional details for the
will still three and four can be found
in the paper but anyway uh thanks for
watching